only on CBS this morning Oprah just
revealed on CBS this morning her latest
book club pic and Oprah has agreed to
stay with us to join us because you're
so psyched about the book but I'm so
psyched about the book it's called the
Sun does shine how I found life and
freedom on death row I couldn't sleep
really you know I was so excited about
telling everybody about this book and I
want everybody to go out and get this
book so that I tells the story it tells
the story of Anthony ray Hinton thirty
years on death row for crimes he did not
commit until he was released in 2015 but
we should talk we're having a little
technical issue yes we're having more
than a technical issue so we have to
pass a microphone like they did back in
1952 so please bear with us this is
Anthony ray Hinton the reason why Oprah
was so excited because she normally
doesn't pick memoirs but you were
falsely accused for 30 years and why
this story is so extraordinary you were
accused of what exactly I was Kyuzo to
capital murder and crime that they knew
that I didn't commit and so it took 30
years before I got no release not only
did they know you didn't commit it but
he had passed a polygraph test over what
else happened why this was so egregious
well it was so egregious because the
state of Alabama accused him of doing
something that they didn't have any
evidence for they went back to the house
and got the gun that an old gun that his
mother had had and hadn't been fired for
25 years
the defense attorney paid some guy off
the street to be a ballistics expert it
was legally blind in one eye and who who
you know was not qualified to do
anything not to mention be a ballistics
expert and in that moment mr. Hinton
realized that you were going to lose
that trial correct yes and I just know
they were gonna find me guilty of
capital murder
you knew that even though you passed the
polygraph test
the prosecution talked to the judge and
it was not permissible to be used they
wouldn't allow it yeah so the agreement
was before I took you if I pass I can
use it if I fail the prosecution we use
it and you
then I passed it and let me say an FBI
agent gave it to me gave me the product
girl that guy said he said at the end
this man don't know anything about this
murderer and if I can go by this
polygraph I would take him out of this
jail tonight yeah but what happened mr.
Hinton they just basically decided that
there these two murders had occurred it
had upset the community and somebody was
going to pay yeah yeah the thing that
got me was the fact that I can't imagine
what this angle looks like we but the
thing that got me my nostrils the thing
that got me is that they knew he didn't
do it but they wanted to make the
community feel better and when he went
to his own defense attorney and you said
to your defense attorney would it make
any difference to you if I if I told you
I was innocent he said he said the
problem with that statement
y'all always are doing something y'all
referring to blacks y'all along with
that party always doing something Indian
saying you didn't do it and this is the
me that I had to rely on yeah yeah did
he say is this the one same man that
said if you didn't do it one of your
homies what did detective said that that
arrest me he said this ain't not true to
believe we didn't do it but y'all always
taking up for one another
take this rap for your homeboy and one
of them also said listen you're gonna be
convicted why he said because there's
five thing that's going to convict you
first because you're black second
because the white man is gonna say you
shot him whether you shot him or not I
really don't care he's saying thirdly
you're gonna have a white prosecutor for
for going up a white church and fifth
you're gonna have an all-white jury but
you still kept thinking I'm gonna get
out I'm gonna get out because I didn't
do this
absolutely you know I wanted to believe
that the justice system didn't work that
way
I had never been convicted of being
involved in anything serious like that
and so I just didn't believe that they
was more that there was more in tune to
finding the true killer I didn't just
think they was going to put someone to
eat
the the business community and they
wanted to make the business community
feel safe again
what happened keep going so but so how
do you how do you hold on to hope when
you've been sense it it took two hours
for the trial two hours and then for two
hours for deliberations and then 45
minutes you convicted to death how do
you all hold on to hope when you've
already gone this far because you're
thinking they'll never convict me I
certainly won't be sitting to death how
do you hold on to hope knowing that you
know you shouldn't have been there
well it's the way that I was brought up
my mother brought me up through faith
told me that God can do everything but
fail and at that moment I realized
everything then I thought that okay they
gonna find out and I got true to believe
that they was gonna look at this more
and say hey Christian we made a mistake
but as time went on and once the judge
sentenced me to death I got to death row
and tell them about the moment you're in
the courtroom and you hear the guilty
verdict I thought this was so
interesting because I you know the whole
time you're reading this book you you
can't help but put yourself in his shoes
and think about what looking what would
this what would this mean for me we'd
also like to take your questions if you
have something for Oprah mr. Hinton go
ahead yeah III was thinking about what
would I do what would I do what I do
first of all I wouldn't have been able
to survive the way you did and I have
great you do good service no the reason
I couldn't survive is because the cell
was 5x7
yes no windows no no windows is
obviously on death row and you you don't
see a tree or a blade of grass I I
actually could not survive without
seeing something in nature that I
wouldn't make it I was just looking at
concrete my whole life but the fact that
when you were sentenced that you said
there's a that you went blind for a
month I think I would too and you've out
and speak no you didn't work for three
years three years you didn't say a word
when he said it I sentence you to death
and I look back and I knew my niece was
back there behind me
and at that moment my eyesight was gone
I didn't know who she was and and I just
had to sit down and I sit down and my
eyesight came back for that moment and I
just couldn't believe it I mean I don't
even to this thing
know how to explain the feeling the
sadness the disappointment and I felt
there but it is there
hope everything that my mom told me I
know my mom would never lied to me and I
kept saying
where were you god yeah what was you
when I needed you you know what else you
said in the book about your mother
you said you your mom would say how are
you doing you told her I'm fine I'm fine
everything's good they're treating me
real good you said sometimes you believe
it's important to tell a lie to protect
the person that you love a few and to be
kind to the person I lied to her
repeatedly to song and I was I lied to
her to protect her because I know she
would protect me and I kept one and I
actually I said it's mom okay and he
said I still think she in shock and I
began to believe she was trying to act
as though everything was normal to
protect me in the way she knew how I
love and care about one of the things
that really struck me so much is I did
an interview with mr. Hinton supersoul
on this coming Sunday and you said you
really believe your mother died of a
broken heart yes I truly believe that in
oh she didn't get to see you free she
died 2002 yes and for years she would
come to prison and say when you comin
home yeah that's the only question she
had when they gonna let you go
and I said mom they're working on it
I'll be home soon and soon ended up 30
years yeah cuz you went to prison 19 why
you see 1986 and she died in 2002 so he
never got yes she freaked and when I got
worried that she had died I told Bryan
Stevenson I don't give a damn about this
case and I hung up on him and I tried to
sleep at night but I couldn't it was as
though my mother came in that sale and
just got in my head and say I'm very
disappointed that you wouldn't give up
and you heard your mom's dad raise a
quitter yes
what is amazing about it quick before
you do the questions can I just say
what's amazing about those 30 years you
know Gayle and I've been friends now for
I think 40-something Oh since we were 21
in 63
okay the whole time I was reading about
lessor I thought lester is your gales
and Lester because this is what Gayle
would do for me I know I would do it for
me I would do it for you I might have
missed a week ago you were 30 years
Lester you should his best friend his
best friend Lester for 30 years they
were six and four years old have been
four best friends and he never missed a
weekend of coming to see him in prison
Lester you are
why Lester you never missed a week why I
couldn't found him you know not being
with him nuts it's bad enough when you
talk to someone day in and day out yeah
and to not be around him you know it was
just you never doubted his innocence no
never questioned the conversation never
came up
yeah you know and when you all read the
book you'll see it's so ridiculous he
was at work he was clocked at alibi had
an alibi it was a white man you thought
that because your boss your supervisors
lying start oh my god yeah white men
will tell them the truth
thank God thank you God it's a white my
supervisor is white go to him and
irritate me they come back and said we
got good news and bad news the good news
we no longer gonna charge you for this
but we decided that we're gonna charge
you for this and that supervisor
couldn't say anything for those who knew
each other he couldn't say he was
working and that's how I think but just
a gun that hadn't been fired for 25
years it clearly couldn't have been the
murder weapon that was enough passing
the polygraph that wasn't enough no
having an alibi that wasn't enough so
enter Bryan Stevenson who has to be an
angel among angels for you
Oprah talk about Bryan Steve Bryan
Stevenson founded the equal justice
Institute in Montgomery Alabama and he
is
spent his life freeing people from not
just death row but freeing them from
situations where they were where there's
evidence that they were falsely accused
and he is a big part of the the the
fight for equal justice in this country
and to fight mass incarceration and he
said to about your story that no stories
affected him out of the way yes this one
the same thing that operates and in his
book just mercy he begins his book
talking about the case with Anthony Rea
Hinton he is an angel among yes if it
wasn't for EJ I I truly believe the
state of Alabama had every intention and
it was just waiting on the date from the
Supreme Court to execute yeah and they
knew that I was innocent we big the
state of Alabama to reexamine the
bullets and I often ask people why
didn't reassembled because they already
knew that the bullets didn't matter
they've never apologized you and from
the state of Alabama's point of view
you're still a guilty man yes yes
they've never apologized yes yes yeah I
want the state of Alabama to apologize
that is what I want is the state of
Alabama to apologize and I want people
to buy this book and read this book and
understand that there are hundreds and
thousands of Anthony Rae Hinton's in out
there in the mass incarceration system
that deserve the opportunity for justice
but before we go the most one of them
there are so many compelling stories we
keep saying that but Henry Hayes is a
white man who's on death row with you a
former Klansmen yes you don't know that
he's white but you always say compassion
has no color the reason you don't know
he's white is because when you're on
death row you just can't you can't see
you can't see each other yeah yes well
Henry went out and did something heinous
and him and never did nineteen-year-old
blast and you know Henry Lynch yes
genitals yes very heinous this is the
first white man convicted in 86 years in
a state of Alabama for killing a black
yes yeah
and when he came in you know we became
to talking I didn't see his color any of
that but I realized that Henry had been
cheated in life his mother and father
told him they hate from the day he was
conceived his neighborhood had told him
- he didn't conceive and I often wonder
when Henry went to school he had to use
words that would make the teachers say
he'd been talking Rice's but if you go
to school with a wimp on him on a mark
that teaches by law have to call the
authorities and they will remove that
child from that home and I often wonder
when I got to know Hays why didn't the
authority DHR going to protect this
child
well societies say that it takes a
village to raise a child
what was this village when Ava was being
mental abuse and so what we did on death
row I began to teach chase about law and
I truly believe that just as you program
to hate you can be deprogrammed to look
and so we taught Hays and we showed her
love and we respect - hey we never did
George Hayes because every man that was
there accused and been convicted of a
heinous crime you say there's no racism
absolutely absolutely and what I love
most on the night of Henry execution
they asks you two things what would you
like to have for your last meal and what
would you like to say and the night of
his execution Hayes 8 or 8 ounce steak
and he said all of my life I've been
taught to hate the very people that I've
been taught to hate or the very people
that taught me what love was all about
all my life he's been told taught to
hate black people
oh yes yeah and he said tonight I leave
this world knowing what true love feel
like and they put things to death yeah
and I know that if he could have been
reached on death row imagine if someone
had tried to reach him earlier earlier
and I think society bear a
responsibility as well so does your
passion about this book you want to do
what you
I said before you came mr. Hinton that I
have not seen her as excited about a
book since color purple where she said I
will literally pass a book out to
strangers on the street yeah I've never
seen her as excited about it because I
think it's important time in our culture
in our history for people to understand
what it means to be on death row and
what it means to say yeah give him the
death sentence when a quarter of the
people who are there should not actually
be there and a quarter yeah yes and when
there's also such in justices when you
are poor and a person of color black
Hispanic and you cannot afford to have
lawyers it's better to be guilty and
rich poor and innocent and so that's why
I think this book is so important and
you are a symbol for all of the people
who deserved to be set free are you
issuing a challenge yes well this is
what I'm hoping is that everybody will
read the book and then you'll really
have a lot of questions for Lester and
for mr. Hinton and we're gonna come
together again in late June we'll let
you know when that is and I'm going to
invite you Lester and you mr. Hinton to
Maui well where I was gonna be
vacationing oh but let's vacation
together vacation I want to come we'll
do a Facebook live we didn't say kill
you can come Facebook live Facebook live
for my front yard okay let's do that
do you have one question before we go
Brandon did any of your guards believe
you were innocent yes any of your hearts
believe you were I would actually say
nanny passing of the guard when mr.
Stevenson would come to the prison
frankly they would ask me what can I do
to help you help him out of here yeah
because he don't belong yeah you know
just before I said this on CBS this
morning the Gayle and I were talking
about the book is when I really like a
book I get excited and I was like have
you read it yet and so she was preparing
for this morning she was saying gosh I
really like mister
why do I like mr. Anton so much Gail and
I had the honor and pleasure of spending
a lot of time with Nelson Mandela before
he died and I remember the time we were
sitting at the table and your son will
said can you pass the peanuts and I said
I'm gonna remember this please so we
spend a lot of time with Nelson Mandela
and one of the things that you recognize
when you immediately in the presence of
Nelson Mandela is his goodness and his
kindness as effective and His grace
effect that he spent 27 years in prison
and invited the guards to his
inauguration
Anthony Rea Hinton has the spirit of
Nelson Mandela one of the first people
I've ever met who is actually a gentle
man who has that spirit of grace and
kindness and forgiveness forgiveness
that you can spend 30 years on death row
and know that you were innocent and not
have the state of Alabama apologized to
you but you come out with no bitterness
like why do you have that fairness and
bitterness killed the soul and I truly
believe that those men in the state of
Alabama did this for whatever they
reason with it I cannot sit back and
wait on an apology I have a life that I
want to live but you lost so much of
your lydian and I have gained so much
anything I didn't forgive those men so
they could sleep good at night I forgave
them so I could sleep good at night and
so I think that I deserve that
just sleep good at night you just
deserve that and even more yeah that the
Sun does shine y'all please buy this
books on him to go stand on the corner
wherever you buy books wherever you buy
them Amy's going everywhere like to buy
your way